Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Have a look at this magnificent idea: the
input is a digital 3D model of an object and
a viewpoint of our choice, and the output
is an easy to follow, step by step breakdown
on how to draw it.
Automated drawing tutorials!
I wish tools like this were available back
when I was a child!
Awesome!
This technique offers a way to create the
scaffoldings to help achieving the correct
perspective and positioning for the individual
elements of the 3D model, something that novice
artists often struggle with.
This problem is particularly challenging,
because we have a bunch of competing solutions
and we have to decide which one should be
presented to the user.
To achieve this, we have to include a sound
mathematical description of how easy a drawing
process is.
The algorithm also makes adjustments to the
individual parts of the model to make them
easier to draw without introducing severe
distortions to the shapes.
The proposed technique uses graph theory to
find a suitable ordering of the drawing steps.
Beyond the scientific parts, there are a lot
of usability issues to be taken into consideration:
for instance, the algorithm should notify
the user when a given guide is not to be used
anymore and can be safely erased.
Novice, apprentice, and adept users are also
to be handled differently.
To show the validity of this solution, the
authors made a user study where they tested
this new tutorial type against the most common
existing solution, and found that the users
were not only able to create more accurate
drawings with it, but they were also enjoying
the process more.
I commend the authors for taking into consideration
the overall experience of the drawing process,
which is an incredibly important factor - if
the user enjoyed the process, he'll surely
come back for more, and of course, the more
we show up, the more we learn.
Some of these tutorials are available on the
website of the authors, as always, I've linked
it in the video description.
If you are in the mood to draw, make sure
to give it a go and let us know how it went
in the comments section!
Hell, even I am now in the mood to give this
a try!
If I disappear for a while, you know where
I am.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!